it was clear to all of us that borders
can no longer be moved by force
and that the sovereignty of states
must be respected, the law has
been broken by russia and therefore
nobody can assume that the
russian president and the russian
government will not also do this on other
occasions  the right of peoples and
our understanding would break by
force that is the reason why
we all decided at the same time that
we should expand our defense efforts
finland and sweden are
friendly countries the two prime
ministers are also close friends
of mine if i
may say so we are close  connected to each other
it is therefore important for
me to say on this occasion that we are
following the
debate that is taking place in both countries very closely about a
possible entry into our
defense alliance of nato these
are decisions and discussions that
have to take place there on the spot in
Finland and Sweden will be
hit but it is clear to us that if
these two countries decide
that they want to belong to the alliance
then they can count on our support
[Music]